los ríos
llevan agua en verano aunque no haya
llovido durante muchas semanas
nunca os habéis preguntado de dónde
viene esa agua
si es así no sois los únicos ya
aristóteles y descartes se preguntaron
esa es la misma pregunta y llegaron a
conclusiones bastante equivocadas como
que por ejemplo el agua que fluye por
los ríos en verano aunque no haya
llovido procede del mar y llega hasta
allí a través de unos conductos
subterráneos complejos que se concentran
en el centro de la tierra donde hay un
gran vaso una vasija es donde se
evaporan pierde la salinidad y llegan a
la superficie
ya desde el siglo 18 y hoy en día
sabemos que el agua que llevan los ríos
aunque no haya llovido durante muchas
semanas proviene de la infiltración de
la lluvia
es agua subterránea que es parte del
ciclo hidrológico
el ciclo hidrológico lo conocemos todos
sobre todo en su parte superficial pero
hay una componente subterránea que quizá
no conozcamos tanto y es de esta
elección me gustaría
el circuito lógico comienza con la
elaboración del agua del mar que
asciende hasta la atmósfera se mueve por
la circulación atmosférica y regresa
hasta la superficie en forma de lluvia
me gustaría que nos concentráramos en la
lluvia eso me gustaría me gustaría que
sintieras la lluvia
ah
hoy las gotas de lluvia
están cayendo cosas que están cayendo
están cayendo algunas se evaporan
algunas se quedan interceptadas por los
árboles en las ramas o en las hojas casi
todas llegan al suelo
se infiltran y al principio cuando el
suelo está seco se quedan retenidas en
los primeros centímetros del terreno del
suelo está ávido de humedad y tiene una
capacidad de absorción importante
sigue lloviendo
[Música]
sigue infiltrando se el agua pero se
queda retenida en el suelo sigue
lloviendo y llega un momento en que solo
ya no es capaz de retener más agua a
partir de ese momento el agua por una
parte escurre por la superficie en esa
escorrentía superficial que dará lugar a
los ríos y por otra parte se infiltra
una escorrentía subterránea
va infiltrando
[Música]
infiltrando sigue moviéndose atraída por
la gravedad hasta que llega a un lecho a
un estrato impermeable que ya no puede
pasar sigue lloviendo y las aguas se van
acumulando sobre ese estrato impermeable
acumulando agua el agua va rellenando
todos los poros todas las fracturas
todos los resquicios va elevándose el
nivel freático que sería el nivel que
veríamos si hiciéramos un pozo en ese
punto
sobre una superficie muy grande sobre
espesores importantes ahí tenemos un
acuífero
los acuíferos son
prácticamente ubicuos tenemos el agua
sabemos que se infiltra por cualquier
rendija
en españa concretamente en la españa
peninsular que estoy mostrando aquí el
70% de la superficie debajo de ella
tiene un acuífero
excepto por las cuencas del ebro algo en
el guadiana y algo en el tajo el resto
tenemos un acuífero
pero el agua en los acuíferos no está
nuestra están acá exactamente igual que
hay una escorrentía superficial
tenemos una escorrentía subterránea el
agua superficial y está intentando
buscar el punto más bajo el punto de
desagüe el agua subterránea es lo mismo
la diferencia es la velocidad a la que
se mueve
el agua superficial se mueve
aproximadamente a un metro por segundo
de manera que si yo fuera un río mi agua
pues tardaría unos pocos segundos llega
la primera fila quizás diez segundos un
poco más arriba 15 segundos en atravesar
la sala
ahora bien en el subsuelo
imaginaos y decir el agua tiene que
moverse entre esos poros es que casi
cada molécula de agua tiene que pedir
paso para poder moverse roza con los
materia con el material a través del que
está moviéndose
lo que tenemos es un movimiento mucho
más lento más lento podríamos hablar por
ejemplo de un metro por día esa misma
agua que antes en cinco segundos estaba
en la primera fila ahora tardará cinco
días
diez días para llegar al medio quince
días para llegar al final de la sala
en ese movimiento ese movimiento lento
se encontrará con un cauce
entonces aflorar a ese agua en el río o
se podrá encontrar con una depresión y
saldrá una fuente
o se podrá encontrar con una llanura y
la inundará y se producirá un humedal
qué importante son los acuíferos no
son los responsables de que el agua
fluya por los ríos en verano
de muchas semanas
que tengamos fuentes que tengamos
humedales
pero quizá más importante es que dan de
beber a un tercio de la población
mundial
2.600 millones de personas beben todos
los días agua procedente
el 50 por ciento de la población de la
comunidad valenciana debe todos los días
hago de los acuíferos el cien por cien
de los habitantes de la provincia de
castellón beben agua subterránea
el 80% de los municipios con menos de
20.000 habitantes
utilizan agua subterránea para
abastecerse
algunos datos
[Música]
total de agua que tenemos en el globo
pues aproximadamente el 97% de ese agua
es agua salada agua salada que está en
los mares unos océanos
sólo un 3% es agua dulce
de esa agua dulce
la mayor parte de ella está ubicada en
los polos en los glaciares y en las
nieves perpetuas un 69%
el 30% es agua subterránea es algo de
las que estábamos hablando y sólo un 1
por ciento es agua superficial y de ese
agua superficial la mayor parte de ella
están los grandes lagos o sea que los
ríos y en las presas y demás hay muy
poquita agua
el mensaje es que hay hay mucha agua
subterránea y 30 veces más agua
subterránea que agua superficial y
además con una distribución muy dispar
el agua subterránea es más o menos
ubicua si hiciéramos un pozo debajo de
nuestros asientos encontraríamos agua a
45 metros de profundidad mientras que el
agua superficial está muy concentrada
está muy localizada
pero el agua subterránea no se utiliza
sólo para dar de beber para abastecer
poblaciones
y os daré algunos datos sobre sobre
españa
en españa también se utiliza para
labores agrarias para el regadío
se utiliza en la industria y luego tiene
otros usos
en total en españa al año se usan unos
30 mil hectómetros cúbicos de agua un
hectómetro cúbico recuerdo es un millón
de metros cúbicos un hectómetro cúbico
como referencia nos sirve para dar agua
de beber a una población de unos 17 mil
habitantes
puede ser silla o la liana
de esos 30 mil hectómetros cúbicos que
se utilizan anualmente en españa 7 mil
provienen de los acuíferos y también
provienen de las aguas subterráneas
como veis con esta distribución la mayor
parte van a la agricultura después a las
te cimiento y luego a la industria y
finalmente otros usos
solamente quiero insistir en la
importancia de esas aguas subterráneas
de las cuales quizás no erais
conscientes
la explotación de los acuíferos es
complicada a los acuíferos tienen la
desventaja de esa ubicuidad que los
hacen muy frágiles
tenemos que cuando esperamos un acuífero
en que yo puedo perforar un pozo en
cualquier sitio y digo empieza a bombear
agua pero tenemos que bombear con cabeza
con cierto sentido debemos de ser
conscientes de qué cantidad de agua se
está infiltrando por lluvia esas lluvias
esas gotas de lluvia que caen
por término medio al año e intentar no
superar esa y superar en extracciones
esa cantidad de manera continuada porque
si de manera continuada y sistemática
sacamos más agua del acuífero de la que
está entrando por recarga de lluvia al
final lo que vamos a hacer es vaciar el
acuífero
y pueden ocurrir cosas como por ejemplo
en el valle de san joaquín en california
que durante 50 años estuvieron sacando
agua con desmesura y el valle el valle
no una pequeña localidad ni una zona del
valle entero se hundió 50 metros
entre 1925 y
en 50 años se hundió 9 metros 9 metros
puede ser la altura de éste
de este espacio que imaginaos que hace
50 años la politécnica estuviera a la
altura que tenemos el techo ahora mismo
el local y se hubiera hundido por la
explotación del acuífero de valencia lo
que lo que tenemos aquí debajo
eso no ha pasado en españa pero sí que
es cierto que hay ciertos acuíferos
donde se está extrayendo más agua de la
que se está recargando
en esta imagen veis en rojo aquellos
acuíferos donde se ha detectado que hay
una extracción importante de agua y
donde las confederaciones hidrográficas
que son los organismos encargados de
velar por la salud de los acuíferos
están tomando medidas están proponiendo
acciones para revertir esa situación
los acuíferos también son muy frágiles
con respecto a la contaminación
recordar esas gotas de lluvia que caen
si al caer entran en contacto con algún
material tóxico
como por ejemplo unos fertilizantes y
puedan disolver nitratos o fosfatos o
unos pesticidas
o una fosa séptica deje de funcionar y
libere en material bacteriano que
después es arrastrado por esas gotas de
lluvia cuando se infiltran
pues lo que acaban es contaminando
en españa también tenemos detectados
algunos acuíferos los que tenéis aquí en
rojo donde se han superado algunos
niveles máximos de contaminación y sobre
los que se está actuando para entender
intentar
el problema al final con los acuíferos
es lo que primero he hecho como ventajas
nos ubicuidad el hecho de que el agua se
mueva tan despacio que se mueva tan
despacio que su cuidad hace que sea
fácil contaminar los que se mueva tan
despacio hace que sea difícil detectar
la contaminación y cuando se detecta ha
pasado mucho tiempo entonces es difícil
tardamos en detectarlo y luego tardamos
mucho en intentar revertir la situación
porque limpiarlo nos va a costar posible
entre tanto tiempo como el que costó
y de lo que yo quería que fuera de aquí
con la consciencia de que tenéis agua
bajo nuestros pies agua subterránea un
agua invisible de calidad y en cantidad
pero muy frágil muy frágil
un agua que da de beber a un tercio de
la población mundial al 50 por ciento de
la población de la comunidad valenciana
al cien por cien de los habitantes de
castellón
un agua que permite que los ríos fluyan
en verano aunque haga muchas semanas que
no ha llovido
que gestiona que produce las fuentes que
es el responsable de que existan los
humedales
un agua
en algunos puntos de la tierra
la única fuente segura de ese líquido
imprescindible para la vida y recuerdo
que todo empezó con
notas de lluvia que al caer
me traen recuerdos de un gran amor y yo
quiero recordar
[Música]
[Aplausos]